we've used the term social contract
several times already so let's take a
look at what did we mean by this post
World War two social contract and why
did it work so well for so many if you
were born between 1946 and 1964 you're a
member of what we call the baby boom
generation and chances are you did quite
well because you were able to follow
your parents advice of working hard
staying in school and being able to
improve on the standard of living you
achieve for yourself and for your family
compared to what your parents had so was
this all just a matter of luck is there
some iron law of economics that achieved
it well neither are true it took a lot
of hard work and a lot of invention on
the part of labor and management leaders
of the time America came out of World
War two with an enormous amount of
pent-up demand for consumer goods
because we were focused on building the
economy for the war so we had to convert
from factories that may tanks and
military airplanes two factors that made
cars and other kinds of goods and
services that were in high demand in the
post-world war two economy and that
created what we call the post-war social
contract now you've seen this diagram
before it shows that over the post-world
war two time period wages and and
productivity moved in tandem and so as
the economy got better so too did wages
and living conditions for the vast
majority of families of that time so how
did that work well as I said we've had
an enormous amount of growth in
construction in heavy industry in
rebuilding the economy after World War
two we had the rise of mass production
we had automobiles coming out of our
ears here's a picture of how Ford and
General Motors and other companies were
able to produce millions of vehicles for
mass market largely similar kinds of of
goods and services that people were were
looking for so it was out of this time
period that unions began to grow in the
post-world war two time period unions
grew to about thirty to thirty-five
percent but union growth didn't come
easily it took a lot of battles between
labor and management in the steel
industry in the auto industry General
Motors had to experience a sit-down
strike in their plant in 1937 before
unionization was accepted by General
Motors this is a example of what's
called a battle of the overpass where
the auto workers leaders led by Walter
Reuther who were going to hear about a
little bit more specifically in a moment
had to fight with paid security guards
hired by Ford Motor to try to keep the
Union out so this was a battle that went
on not only in autos but in steel and in
many other industries but once it was
successful and once unions were
organized you got something called the
post-war social contract this is an
example of Walter Reuther here
negotiating and signing an agreement
with General Motors which was called the
Treaty of Detroit where the parties
agreed that they would increase wages by
the rate of growth in the cost of living
and the overall average rate of growth
in productivity in the economy and it
was that agreement that allowed wages
then to grow and why we got this tender
movement of wages and productivity for
so many years in the post-war time
period but that was just the auto
industry how did we get this to spread
across the country well to understand
that we have to introduce another term
something that in labor relations
terminology is called pattern bargaining
that is what would happen is you
negotiated a wage agreement at let's say
General Motors and then the union would
carry that same agreement to forward and
say if you don't want to strike then you
should agree to this
same wage and Ford would agree in the
pattern would spread to price to
Chrysler and others in the automobile
industry while not perfect it then also
spread to other industries across the
country at its own rate so you got oil
and gas and household appliances and the
steel industry and aerospace rubber
electronics all of these growing
industries basically following a similar
wage pattern not exactly copying but
fitted to the economic circumstances of
their particular setting and so this is
what created that tandem movement of
wages and productivity and as the
economy got better so too did the
average workforce member and his or her
family's that's the kind of thing that
we then lost since 1980 that's the kind
of thing we have to find a new solution
to create again but the key for us today
is not to try to go back to the 1940s 50
60s or 70s but to ask how can we create
wage norms how can we create the
bargaining power for workers so that we
can once again start to get wages moving
with the overall growth of the economy
that's our challenge moving forward
we'll talk about how to do that in
future sessions
you